honestly guys I'm speechless that's all
I can really say first off of my voice
my voice sounds a little bit different a
little bit rest here I'm sorry I've been
sick for the past like three days and
I've been trying to hold off making
videos but I just really need to get
this out and I just mustered up as much
effort as I could to make this so as
soon as I'm done with this I'm gonna
just go rest and chill out for the
weekend but I just want to thank you all
for 1000 subs and honestly as it is
right now it's actually at 1135 so I
just I'm speechless
this all started a couple weeks ago I
put out like three weeks ago I put out a
Centurion and shinobi moves us tan
executions video that blew up got like
39,000 views like a week later I
released the new executions the one
we're lawbreaker kind of like chokes out
the dude that had 27,000 then I got the
then I had the new season two emotes for
all characters and that looked the
45,000 and the warden one shot glitch
thanks to the shout-out to core Evo has
just reached over 50k as of last night
and then the patch 1.08 summary has
reached 37 thousand views I didn't
honestly expect to get this many views
in this short of time I'm just I'm
absolutely speechless for all the love
and support you guys have shown me and
like I said I'm super sick and it is
really hard to make this [ __ ] video
the amount of times I had to cut this
audio because of me coughing midway
through is pissing me off right now but
I just want to say again guys just thank
you for the 1000 subs and there's no I'm
not stopping here there's no reason for
me to stop here just for the love and
support you guys have given me in the
comments all the beautiful comments
you've seen like oh he deserves more all
the stuff it just makes me go more every
day so I just I just want to thank you
all I'm sorry again for the voice but
hopefully after this video I'll just try
to rest up drink some lots of pee but
just once again I'm just thank you all
guys I don't know what else to say from
that I'm probably going to definitely
going to keep posting more for on our
videos it's definitely helping out this
channel way more I checked social blade
and all them at the beginning of May 5th
it is June's
is June 4th right now so it's almost
a month may fit I had 337 subs and a
month later I've gotten 693 more so
thank you all to all the new people that
came all the old people that are still
with me I love you all equally alright
just I'm just so grateful for all of
this so I'm going to keep posting more
for honor stuff if there's anything else
that comes to during the week I'll post
it if not parts going to chill relax and
then I'm probably to be posting the dead
stream on Thursday hopefully my voice
gets better by Thursday anyway guys it's
going to be the end of the video and I
will see you all in the next video and
peace out guys thank you all for 1000
subs